>> Laura: WOULDN'T YOU KNOW,
COMEDIENNE SAMANTHA BEE IS
SUFFERING PRETTY MUCH NO
CONSEQUENCES AT ALL FOR HER
REPUGNANT ATTACK ON IVANKA
TRUMP.
AND JOY REID, OVER THE LAST FEW
WEEKS, HATEFUL NASTY BLOG POSTS
BY REID HAVE ALL SURFACED.
SHE'S REPEATLY APOLOGIZED FOR
THE POSTS.
THE NETWORK SAID SHE HAS
EVOLVED.
AND HER SHOW REMAINS ON THE AIR.
JOINING ME NOW, ONE OF REID'S
TARGETS, ANN COULTER.
ANN, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
I'M SURE NONE OF THIS SURPRISES
YOU.
THIS IS WHAT YOU AND I HAVE
BECOME ACCUSTOMED TO.
THE LIBERALS CAN SAY WHATEVER
THEY WANT ABOUT MINORITIES,
JEWS, AND GET AWAY WITH IT.
BUT YOU FOUND INTERESTING
NUGGETS FROM HER PAST.
>> IT ACTUALLY WENT UP ON DAILY
CALLER TODAY.
SHE WAS WISHING FOR YOU AND ME
TO BE LEFT IN THE PUBLIC SQUARE
IN IRAQ, WHICH I THINK IS
INTERESTING, BECAUSE I AGREE, I
WOULDN'T WANT TO GO TO A
MAJORITY MUSLIM COUNTRY.
I DON'T KNOW WHY LIBERALS WANT
TO TURN THIS COUNTRY INTO THOSE
COUNTRIES.
BUT YOU CONSIDER THAT REALLY,
YOU KNOW, THE WORST THING YOU
CAN DO TO US.
IN A SEPARATE POST, I GUESS SHE
LIKED OR RETWEETED SOMEONE
SUGGESTING THAT, I DON'T KNOW IF
IT WAS JUST ME OR BOTH OF US,
KILL OURSELVES.
AND THE ALWAYS POPULAR CALLING
ME A MAN FOR HAVING A BEAUTIFUL
SWAN-LIKE NECK.
LIBERAL WOMEN AS LONG AS WE'RE
BEING FRANK HERE ARE NOT USED TO
THAT, BECAUSE THEY HAVE ROLLS OF
FAT ON THEIR NECK, TAKEN ABACK
BY MY BEAUTIFUL SWAN-LIKE NECK.
BUT THESE NASTY THINGS THAT GET
POSTED BY LIBERALS, IT SHOWS
THEY JUST WANT TO GET RID OF
ROSEANNE.
I'VE BEEN TOLD MY ENTIRE LIFE,
OH, NO, NEWSPAPERS, TV STATIONS,
ARE JUST TRYING TO MAKE MONEY.
IT'S WHATEVER THE PUBLIC WANTS.
NO, IT ISN'T.
IT HAS NEVER BEEN THAT.
LIBERALS SAY MUCH, MUCH WORSE
THINGS.
BUT THEY'RE PART OF THE
POLITICAL AGENDA.
THE REASON THEY WANTED TO FIRE
ROSEANNE WAS, I MEAN, SHE USED
TO BE KIND OF A LEFT-WING LOON.
SHE BECAME A TRUMP SUPPORTING
STILL KIND OF A LOON.
BUT SHE HAD A WILDLY POPULAR
PROGRAM, AND APPARENTLY WAS
POPULAR WITH TRUMP SUPPORTERS
WHO ENJOY CALLING RACISTS.
>> Laura: CAN YOU SEE THEY'RE
MAYBE TRYING TO REBOOT THE SHOW
WITHOUT HER, WITH JUST HER
DAUGHTER, WHO IS OBVIOUSLY THE
MORE LIBERAL CHARACTER, WHICH
JOHN GOODMAN SAID, I WOULD BE UP
FOR THAT.
HALF OF THE COUNTRY WHO VOTED,
VOTED FOR TRUMP, ROUGHLY.
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE ARE LOOKING
FOR SOMETHING THAT JUST DOESN'T
OFFEND THEM ON A
MINUTE-BY-MINUTE BASIS.
THIS SHOW KIND OF HAD FUNNY
MOMENTS, FOR SOMEONE WHO LIKED
TRUMP WASN'T RIDICULED EVERY
FIVE SECONDS.
POLITICAL OF A SHOW.
BUT I BET THE PRODUCERS, PEOPLE
BEHIND THE SHOW, THEY WERE TIRED
OF HAVING TO ANSWER FOR IT AT
VARIOUS SOCIAL EVENTS IN L.A. OR
MALIBU.
THIS IS A NICE KIND OF UGLY WAY
OF SAYING, OH, THIS IS OFF THE
AIR, WE CAN GO BACK TO DOING
BUSINESS AS NORMAL, ANN.
>> RIGHT.
RIGHT.
I MEAN, I NEVER SAW THE OLD
SHOW, OR THE NEW SHOW, BUT WHEN
SHE WAS GETTING RATINGS LIKE WE
HAVEN'T EVEN HEARD OF, FOR 20
YEARS, TO BE DUMPING THAT SHOW
BECAUSE OF CRAZY TWEETS SHE WAS
SENDING?
SHE HAS ALWAYS SENT CRAZY
TWEETS.
THIS IS NOTHING NEW.
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, I DON'T WANT
TO BE SENT TO A CONCENTRATION
CAMP.
YES, I CONDEMN HER TWEET, BUT
SHE'S ALWAYS SENT CRAZY TWEETS
THAT DESERVED CONDEMNATION.
IF THEY REALLY CARED ABOUT
OFFENSIVE TWEETS, AND SO ON,
OBVIOUSLY SAMANTHA BEE AND JOY
REID WOULDN'T BE ON AIR.
>> Laura: ANN, I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT WHERE THIS PARTY IS GOING.
I TALKED EARLIER TO DINESH ABOUT
THIS, AND HOW EVERYTHING HAS
BECOME RADICALIZED.
THEY CLAIM TRUMP IS A RADICAL,
WHERE HE'S PRETTY MAINSTREAM AND
WANTS TO WORK WITH DEMOCRATS ON
TRADE AND OTHER ISSUES.
YET WE SEE THE DEMOCRATS
LURCHING TOWARDS PERHAPS AN
ELIZABETH WARREN, MAYBE COREY
BOOKER IN 2020.
AND THEN YOU HAVE THE OLD
ESTABLISHMENT FIGURES LIKE JOHN
BOEHNER, A COUPLE OF DAYS AGO,
HE CAME OUT AND HE'S STILL
SNIFFING AND HA RUMFING CLEARLY
ABOUT DONALD TRUMP.
LET'S WATCH.
>> I WANT TO TALK TO YOU BUT
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
>> THERE ISN'T A REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
THERE'S A TRUMP PARTY.
REPUBLICAN PARTY HAS KIND OF
TAKEN A NAP SOMEWHERE.
>> Laura: WHAT DO YOU THINK
ABOUT OLD BOEHNER'S COMMENT?
>> I HOPE IT'S NOT A NAP.
I HOPE IT'S DEAD.
I WANT THE REPUBLICAN PARTY TO
BE THE TRUMP PARTY.
WE MIGHT START WINNING AGAIN.
BUT I THOUGHT JOHN BOEHNER WAS
OFF PROMOTING MARIJUANA OR
SOMETHING.
>> Laura: HE JOINED THE
MARIJUANA BOARD.
HE WAS ALWAYS AGAINST MARIJUANA,
UNTIL HE JUST BECAME AN ADVISORY
BOARD MEMBER OF -- IN OTHER
WORDS, KIND OF INFORMAL LOBBYIST
FOR LEGALIZING POT ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES.
>> AND YOU WONDER WHY I WANT THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY DEAD.
JUST MOVE IT ASIDE.
I MEAN, IT SHOULD GO THE WAY OF
THE WIIGS.
THIS IS A GREAT TURNING POINT AS
IT WAS WHEN LINCOLN TOOK OVER.
THAT PARTY HAS SERVED ITS
PURPOSE.
ALL IT DID WAS LOSE ELECTIONS,
SERVE CORPORATE INTERESTS.